all right welcome everybody to session
this is I think 24 of classic metal
class and this is a uh special one
because we have a guest who's been here
involved in these classes quite a lot
Kenneth Blackwell and the reason why
we're doing this is Ken is you could say
our expert witness and um Memory Bank of
something that we've we talked about in
the past
but want to get back into now a really
important time in the development of
classic metal it's what we call the new
wave of British heavy metal and you know
just to like give a little bit of
background so Scott and I are both of
course from America basically the
Midwest we got to see this you could say
from the outside so the bands who were
able to rise to prominence they got
their they got themselves into our
cataloges think about Raven for example
or of course the very famous Iron Maiden
but there's a lot of bands that just
didn't make it I I would I would guess
that for every band that did there's
probably 20 or so bands that got
together played some gigs didn't quite
catch on maybe never got a record deal
and Ken was lucky enough to be there in
the mix so to speak and we've talked
about this at various times we wanted to
bring him on to pick his brain and put
him on the spot and ask about these
different memories and get his take on
these sorts of things so I I think this
will be a really uh fun one and thanks
so much Ken for you know being willing
to come on and and chat with us about
this um should we do you want to do any
sort of like introduction tell people a
bit about yourself um well can do um
grew up in in Wales which is part of
Great Britain but not England uh and
very quickly I mean from a a really
younger age than I probably ought to
have got got involved in the the sort of
rock music and and medal scene I mean
I've said before that I was bought my
first Iron Maiden tape when I was four
years old I wasn't quite four years old
but I was certainly under 10 I was like
eight or nine probably or something and
um that in itself is is a bit of a
strange story which we may or might not
get into later but yeah it it was I feel
privileged to be honest um having had
the opportunity to be there while so
many bands had their um in some cases
had their heyes um and never made it
some that really ought to have made it
because I think there was some serious
Talent there that never got further than
sort of playing in local pubs and things
like that um the metal scene today I
think would have possibly been quite
different had a lot of those bands had
their uh had the chance that they
deserved um and yeah I saw really if
depending on how we Define the new wave
of British heavy metal saw it through
from its Inception to when when really
the the shutters came down on it in
about where should we put this like
light late 1983 early 1984 it's like the
the whole scene just closed and
disappeared with the exception of some
uh some particular bands who I'm sure
we'll also get to chat about but yeah
essentially I think I think the word
expert is doing some heavy lifting but
it was it was certainly good to have
been there at the time and experienced
that that music when it was actually
happening
definitely so at the risk of like you
know going way off into left field
something that you said is really quite
interesting you know the curtain coming
down I mean do you think that it was
partly a matter of being too successful
as a musical movement so like you know
some bands were able to be attain like a
worldwide status Tour all over the place
um maybe others uh they they got to pass
the torch and then now for others it was
just too late you know to to get into
the game um I think in some parts yes in
in other parts no and what I mean by
that in certain parts yes because I mean
we we talk about bands like I mean there
were loads of others but bands like
Saxon Maiden priest um mahad although I
wouldn't necessarily categorize them as
a new band uh Black Sabbath similarly
wouldn't categorize them as an a wobin
band but anyway when those bands got
International recognition I think that
really changed the focus in some ways uh
in terms of a global metal scene moving
from there's this metal scene in this
country this metal scene in that country
and made it Global um which to some
extent took away a focus from some of
the local metal scenes so uh there was
thinking back I mean this may be a bit
hyperbolic but primarily I blame Kang
magazine for the for the the
cancellation effectively of of the new
wave of British Heavy Metal the reason
being when did this start probably sort
of late 83 early 84 there was an
increasing focus on um I mean rightly so
because there was some bloody good music
came out of there but increasing focus
on the start of what would become thrash
on the start of what would become death
metal um lots of lots of those bands
originating from America and it's as if
the focus of the press at least not so
much fans but certainly the focus of the
press in Shi almost entirely away from
what was going on in the UK um and I
think that lack of focus led to because
we got to remember this is early 80 so
there's nothing eveno approximate in the
internet that didn't even exist you read
magazines or you didn't know about it
effectively unless you go and see the
bands at a local venue so uh certainly
in terms of the press interest that led
to a lack of focus on a lot of bands who
therefore never got publishing deals
with with record labels who probably
ought to have done uh so that in
combination with people thinking well I
can't make any money out of this so much
as I love playing in this band with my
mates I need to pay my mortgage and need
to pay the electricity bill so I'm going
to go and get a 95 job or or doing
whatever um which led to the end of a
lot of those metal Bounds at the time
you know that again we're sort of Off
Script here but I think that's great so
you mentioned metal magazines and Scott
and I have talked about this a number of
times out where I lived nobody read King
because you just couldn't get it no and
we had circus and hit parader and circus
had been established and I think hiter
too for quite a long time before they
became much more about hard rock and
heavy metal and we'd get them at what we
called the dime store the drug store and
uh you'd go in and there was a magazine
rack and youd get it you'd open it up
and there'd always be like a center fold
that you could turn into a poster to
hang in your your room and um you know
there all these other pictures and
there'd be these looking back at it more
or less puff
pieces on the band's interviews with
them you know and it it seems like so if
you if you lived in New York or
something like that okay you might have
had a much better selection that would
include a lot of these British magazines
and you know I've I've looked at Kang um
New Wave of British heavy metal
apparently looking at the history of it
it it's got a really strong connection
to this magazine sounds which again we
didn't have access to either but were
there a lot of other magazines that you
were reading and your friends were
reading that gave you a sense of like
okay this is a band I should go to see
when they come around or here's a record
I need to get my hands on yeah um so the
the really the main two uh certainly in
the early to mid 80s I can't remember
which way around this happened but there
was there was Kang magazine which was
London based published from London okay
there was a a magazine I don't know if
they still exist I think they probably
do called metal Hammer which was also a
London based magazine and then there was
sound really the primary to and this is
just my memory I might be wrong about
this but certainly from what I remember
if you were a Metalhead then the two
magazines you read fairly religiously
were were karang and metal hammer and
there was about one of them started in '
81 I think the other one started in
early ' 84 I can't remember which way
around it was which came first but yeah
those were certainly the two primary
ones um I mean there was other stuff as
well I mean occasionally you you could
get your hands on a copy of of hit parer
which might have some rock artists in it
and that sort of thing but really for
for for metal fans the two primary ones
were Kang and metal Hammer I I'm pretty
sure they I don't think they they either
of them are print magazines anymore but
certainly they've got websites you know
and they still publish articles and
stuff so yeah were there smaller
magazines with you know less circulation
more what we would nowadays call Zen
that were also reflective of the metal
scene not that I remember not really I
mean
occasionally if you had a particular
area with an established scene like um
in London for example there
was oh God what was the name of it it
wasn't a magazine but it was almost like
a circular newsletter that you you could
write off to somebody and they'd put
your name on the drro list and then once
you know once every every few months you
get this paper that somebody had printed
off at home with a copy of some of some
articles you know one or two articles
and a list of upcoming albums that the
readership might be interested in that
sort of thing but certainly in terms of
print magazines it was uh very much
focused on Kang and metal
Hammer that's that's quite interesting
so you know some of the other components
of the scene that I thought again
looking at things from the outside and
and I think Scott you can you can talk a
good bit about this as a musician
yourself that were important for you
know constituting almost like an
ecosystem you've got the magazines
you've got record companies including
new ones like neat that you know get
established and and um print a lot of
these these things and then there's the
venues and I really want to talk with
you about like what it was like going to
these pubs and clubs and you know this
entire vast
um again ecosystem that we we just
didn't have over here and maybe doesn't
exist over there quite so much either no
and then the interaction between the
musicians and and fans and Scott what
else do you think is part when we talk
about a scene a vital scene that's able
to sustain itself what else really
matters in there that we should ask Ken
about well I you know even thinking like
the Boston scene like any scene um you
know we're talking pre- internet and we
we all all of us remember that um yeah
there was the magazines but um if you
were in some kind of scene there was
always the word of mouth right who yeah
yeah and yeah Ken I would love to know
it's kind of like so you I get you know
you were a metal head and you you know
um what are like what's some kind of
like uh IM I don't want to call it like
maybe last minute you're hanging out on
a Wednesday and it's two in the
afternoon and one of your friends says
hey I we have to check out this band at
soand so know do you have any of those
stories where it's kind of like a last
minute thing it turned out to be a
killer gig yes yeah actually um this
happened to me I mean it happened
frequently like you said that one of
your mates calls you up on a Tuesday
afternoon or whatever and says such and
such a band um playing at the if not the
local pub maybe the pub in the next town
over the this evening we these guys are
really good we should go and see them so
and particularly if you've got some
older friends who might have a car then
four or five of you Pile in the back of
the car and zoom over there and and you
know hilarity usually ensues but um the
the one occasion and I can't remember
for the life of me now the name of the
pub but this happened with someone from
me up M Min that's at the time form me
up and said there's this band playing uh
at this wasn't quite a pub it was like a
combination between
it was an early effort at a combination
between a pub and a nightclub the sort
of
place with with what you could described
now as having had character which at the
time meant that you know if you walk
into walk into the bathroom your feet
stuck to the floor and you know that
sort of thing and
um as we were arriving this this bus
pulled out not a bus A van pulled up
with a band members in and they were
taking all this stuff out the back of
the van and cting it into the venue and
all this sort of thing so um this friend
of mine and I walked over and only had
like a two three minute chat with the
band members I didn't have a clue who
they were at the time turned out it was
Biff biford and Saxon oh
wow I don't have a foggiest idea who
were who they were and that night was
also the first time I ever heard
um oh so would this would have been it
would have been uh Wheels of Steel okay
and that made a hell of an impression I
mean imagine in hearing Wheels of Steel
for the first time live that that was
one of those wow I love this moments you
know um and similar with uh another band
worthy um it
wasn't oh uh very similar thing happened
but the Bandon question were which
finder General
oh wow and it was a bit odd because I
mean they usually get lumped in with
with uh new wer British heavy metal
bands but there was a bit I think
there's a bit of a distinction to be
made there because quite a few of those
there was kind of a subset of noin bands
who were very much and this goes to the
whole noan thing having been to some
extent a bit of a counterculture uh
against the the prevailing attitudes in
in Britain at the time but there was a
whole subset of noin bands that had kind
of a theatrical horror stroke Satanism
theme going on you got which ferren
there was a band called hell we're going
to talk about again later on hopefully
um there was a band called demon um I
made a list of these somewhere there was
a band called Holocaust there was a band
called uh Grim Reaper yeah yeah Angel
witch I mean there was loads of them and
they as a in sharp contrast because
people think that that's or some people
at least have apped that that's where
black metal started but it isn't not at
all these were all bands that had a very
kind of theatrical bent on on the
subject matter they were you could
almost call them like thespian metal for
one of a better description rather than
being anything that you know the WWA
Hill Satan Brigade um it it was it was a
very different take on the whole thing
um so yeah that was another fascinating
uh I didn't have a clue which finder
General were but they were great very
very good life of act and oh when I was
gonna sorry to interrupt when I was what
I was going to ask is we should make a
distinction here um what you mean by Pub
because uh right because oh right
because NAD Nadia is always telling me
this is not a pub or this is not a
proper Pub or you know to me so to me
because because we're we're in an
American context and the word Pub has
been sort of used and abused for all
sorts of things right so I picture it as
you know you walk in it's just a bar and
then a little tiny stage where where
like maybe smaller bands would play mhm
yes saying like Saxon would come in and
play just a essentially a bar yeah and
yeah that that happened a lot yeah and
even even with bands who who
were well on the way to being huge I
mean this is something that I Maiden did
frequently is that they they turn up I
mean oh what's her name the ruskan arms
in East London was the pub that they
started at and you would get I mean as
in public house in this country where
yes you have a bar load of tables that
sort of thing usually a fireplace they
sometimes serve food but there's
somewhere where people go just to you
know socialize and have a few drinks
some of them made early attempts at
being like crossovers with with venues
or nightclubs and that sort of thing and
yeah they'd have a sometimes in a
separate room sometimes in one corner of
the bar they'd have a stage I mean
stages were occasionally made of like
broken up beer crates or packing crates
and this sort of thing and it was uh
You' get a band dude set up and and play
usually sometimes fairly short but
sometimes they they just do like an
until you drop or until the landlord
throws everyone out what I shouldn't say
this because pubs were supposed to close
at a particular time but you know
whatever until you drop sessions and
those were really in my in my memory the
best because it was a sort of session
where you'd come out of the place
absolutely deaf covered in someone
else's beer and having had a fantastic
you know fantastic session and often
enough often enough particularly with
smaller bands I mean not so much the
bigger bands because they had other
places to be but with smaller bands
they'd stick around and have a drink
with the with the fans afterwards so
there was genuine real and genuine
interaction between the band members and
and the fans which was great I mean
there there's loads of people out there
one of my deep regrets is that that I
never got the opportunity to do this but
there's loads of people out there who
will have sat down and have drinks with
Maiden after a gig or Saxon or wit funer
general or probably Whit snake or you
know loads of those bands in the early
days there there was
a how could you describe it a level of
authent authenticity and very personal
interactions between the bands and the
fans happen so much no well Saxon
interestingly so this is pre-co they
came here and played in
Milwaukee uh along with uh Black Star
Riders which is you know sort of a
spin-off of Thin Lizzy
and um Judah priest on their Firepower
tour and just blocks from here and um
interestingly Saxon after the show they
went across the street to this I listen
is an Irish P not a real Pub but you
know one passes for one here and they
did exactly that they closed the the pub
and one of our friends because Andy and
I were like well show's over got to go
home go to sleep he he's he's the kind
of guy who goes to all the shows so he
went over to the pub because he heard
Saxon was there and he got to like hang
out and chat with uh Biff bord and a few
of the other guys as well you know so
funny it's stories like this you know we
all talk musicians about you know paying
our dues and it's something oh yeah we
don't see that really um in America now
like you know young
people it's gratification or they want
to do it through Tik Tok but I do
remember like watching the documentaries
and Ken I'd be really curious about this
um you know them talking about like you
know Adrien Smith saying I had a little
Vox amp and when I went to Joy Maiden
they had these Marshall Stacks but then
they they kind of essentially lived in
their cars going from Pub to Pub now
they had but they had you know maybe
that first EP
out um or I don't know like what's the
timeline on that like with um with the
first couple of albums like killers they
were still just paying their dues you
know sleeping in cars playing pubs yeah
maybe in an audience that doesn't like
them or yeah I mean at that point once
you got a record deal even then you you
might get some sort of Advance on the
deal so you've got a little bit of money
but that might upgrade you to something
uh that might upgrade you from a vehicle
uh in which if you got stopped by the
police you'd be screwed because they'd
confiscate it uh to something that was
was actually road legal and that might
take you around places and rather than
sleeping in the van you might be able to
afford to sleep in like a bed and
breakfast or something instead so yeah
um certainly
uh so after the soundhouse tapes um
we're talking probably certainly age of
Iron Maiden title album Maybe into early
Killer's time as well then yeah bands
bands would I don't necessarily know if
I menen did that but it wouldn't
surprise me in the slightest because
there were loads of bands who did
exactly that I mean even this is
something that it was it was talking
about this I can't remember whether it
was Aussie or um Tony iomi Sabbath was
talking about doing exactly the same
thing even after they got a record deal
and if memory serves even when they were
preparing to do their first US tour they
were still desperately trying to scrape
together money fil like um amps and gear
and and that sort of stuff so yeah that
used to happen a lot I remember reading
a um interview with uh Mike gallager of
of Raven where he was talking about how
in the early days he and his his brother
um oh John Gallagher and Mark rather
were um going to to junkyards and
finding old speakers and taking the
coils out of them and and assembling
them into things that they they could
use just because they were so uh
so poor so was there was there a lot of
that going on this sort of like it's not
just Punk that was DIY it was also the
metal scene no no no very very much also
also the metal scene I mean I think
something that probably helped that at
the time was that uh I mean amp and
loudspeaker technology wasn't certainly
was nothing like it is today I mean I
have to be careful what I say here
because there's people going to be
watching this down the line who who who
who are steaming with
in in the fact that you know amps could
be sophisticated back then of course
they would but however that doesn't
prevent you from doing exactly that
either raiding an electronic shop um for
for some stuff that they've got on
either that's either secondhand or or
sort of X demo you know that sort of
thing and cobbling together a setup that
will in fact produce some halfway decent
sound for you or at least something that
sounds big enough and loud enough that
you can cart it along with you in in
your nearly derel van and play at the
local public
of an need so yeah now when a band would
make the transition from you know this
whole Circuit of of pubs going all over
the place to larger concert Halls they'd
have to get their hands on a lot more
equipment there weren't Pas like there
are today where you just patch into that
and a a guy at the soundboard who may or
may not be your guy handles it um so was
that like that's where the record
Advance would go to and and you you just
spend it on all this uh equipment that
you would need and you wouldn't have the
fake Stacks like we have now it would
actually be everything is in working
order with with the caveat of never
really having well I was in in a band
for about five minutes before I
discovered I was a crap guitarist but
anyway that's that's fairly irrelevant
um um yes once you get your first transe
of cash from your record label then
absolutely you know you that you might
be um playing a supporter NE as a
supporter NE to some bigger bands um I
mean as has maen dead for priest in the
really early days they I'm pretty sure
they opened for priest a couple of times
so yeah once you finally start getting
some money coming in then yes you can
afford you can afford to sleep somewhere
where you're going to actually sleep for
the night um or can have a party in the
hotel or whatever uh and and also afford
some much better equipment so that
you're not playing with a 5w amplifier
you know you can maybe afford at least a
secondhand Marshall stack so that it
sounds half decent in front of the Pumas
so yeah so as far as venues let's what
what I think we should do now is we're
we're talking about pubs which is like
you know we've all done it the lowest of
low and um let I you know I'm kind of
curious about some of the venues like um
The
Roundhouse right um what what would be
the next level up where it's a club I I
I know the stones did a famous show at
The Roundhouse but I don't know like
what would be like a a proper music club
that maybe held you know 3 to 500 people
what are some of those rooms so uh back
in the day uh up up until actually
relatively recently the place to go if
you're a rock band or a metal band is
the Hammer Smith Odon
yes but that holds how many people a lot
right well these days it it's been
replaced by some huge corporate heap of
crap which I mean it's not what it used
to be at all the place has got no
character anymore I mean it's still got
the name but it's not what it used to be
back in the day I mean I'm pretty sure
you could have fitted a few hundred
people in there probably yeah so I mean
yeah exactly No Sleep Till Hammersmith
exactly I was just going to ask about
that so that got referenced in so many
tracks by so many bands well that's
interesting because I've always pictured
it as a huge venue right that was it was
never huge okay so it's kind of intimate
and and no matter where you were you
could see see the band well you know
it's not like today where they've got
these big screens that you look the
figures are this tiny worlds away from
somewhere like I mean somewhere in even
in London like the O2 Arena which used
to Beil um I mean I saw maiden play
there and it was a fantastic venue
really good Acoustics and all the rest
of it but it really doesn't have the
same kind of authentic intimate feel
that somewhere like the original Hammer
Smith odion did well that's interesting
because there's so many live albums done
at the Hammer Smith odion that's how
know about it yeah yeah I me even Tears
for Fears has one from their 85 tour you
know it's like and and you always think
like wow what is this place and when I
go we would go to London I'd ask people
about it I guess it's not called that
anymore is it no it's called the insect
corporate name here Arena or some
nonsense like that I would always ask
people because I want to go see this
epic place and nobody know what it is
sadly it doesn't exist anymore well let
let me put it this way there is still a
building there with concerts are held
where concerts are held but it's not in
any way the same place that it once was
where all those those awesome live
concerts were I mean I'm pretty sure if
memory serves I might be wrong about
this but I'm pretty sure that the Hammer
Smith aent was the place where the
loudest
ever concert took place which was I
believe
motorad and someone measured this the
sound pressure level and it some insane
number of decb I'm pretty sure when they
did that they passed up Deep Purple
right didn't Deep Purple have a record
for the previous record yeah yeah yeah
wow okay so that's this this is why it
was such a great place to go because the
atmosphere like like I said you you walk
out completely deaf covered in someone
else's beer covered in sweat and Haven
had a marvelous time you know you know
so when we would go to shows right of
course we'd engage in headbanging and
one of the I do remember my ears ringing
and of course I have some some hearing
damage from from that time I have ttis
that will never go away fortunately I
like the the ringing sound um but I
remember coming back from you know we'd
be driving back in our car like you said
with Five Guys piled into it you know it
it would never be like a roomy car
either it would always be like
somebody's chevet or something like that
and our our necks would be just
completely wor out and then the next day
you would really feel it I mean I don't
headbang anymore because I I don't have
the uh the physical capacity for doing
much more than just a gentle back and
forth but you know back then that's
that's what we would do so I mean was
that you know headbanger is sort of a
synonym for metal head was that like
part of the thing you you you headbang
until you can't you can't even raise
your head anymore yes absolutely yeah
yeah yeah yeah and you wake up the next
day with a really sore neck and and end
up taking so many ibuprofen that you
rattle yeah definitely very much so yeah
yeah headbanging was 100% the thing yeah
mosh pits as well uh and oh yeah I mean
sometimes a mosh pit was certainly with
some the more aggressive bands you could
easily mistake a mosh bit for a mass
fight you know with the pushing and
shoving the went on yeah I I don't doubt
it um i' I've actually got some quite
significant scars as a result of stuff
that happened in mosh pits you know now
now that I recall and so I'm talking
about like mid 80s uh rather than early
80s
because I I wasn't going to to concerts
much until High School um it was mostly
like the thrash scene where mosh was a
big deal yeah like you wouldn't be doing
that say at an LA band like Rad or mle
crew um and you you wouldn't be doing
that at like an Iron Maiden concert over
here but was that I mean was that part
like if you went to see an Iron Maiden
show was there a BH pit no and very
rarely no okay but I mean if you got to
see the chance I mean again this is
quite a bit later on but if you got the
chance to go and see like Meade death or
Metallica or Slayer then yeah there's
definitely going to be a mosh pit or or
even some of the um European thrash
bands like creat the German thrash bands
Sodom that sort of thing yeah definitely
mosh pits yeah so one of the things that
you brought up just to shift topic a bit
was can we actually should we Define
this this movement wave of British heavy
metal I mean it's not a genre that's
that's very clear because it includes a
couple different kinds of genres and
maybe gave rise or at least supported
new genres coming about um so I I know
that you have some thoughts on possible
approaches to defining it what what are
your ideas Ken well I've thought about
this quite a lot over the past couple of
weeks and this is actually a really
tough one really tough one I mean I've
seen attempts made at defining no them
by other people and some of them get
quite technical in terms of has to be a
band signed with you know with with one
of these five different record labels
and they have to have been produced by
one of these people that's nonsense
that's that's complete bollocks yeah um
what I would say in terms of of a
definition is
that and this probably happened sometime
between about 75 and 80 is that the
nature of the music that you know was
not really then but certainly now called
um heavy metal and then W did change
definitely changed um probably around 78
to 79 uh what we know as heavy metal
became louder faster more assertive more
aggressive I mean even even if you look
at
um bands who were by then well
established like priest I mean if you
compare albums like Defenders of the
faith and British steel to the earlier
stuff there's definitely a change there
in in in in the uh well the musicality
for one of a better description I was
thinking Black Sabbath as well I mean
when you look at the late azy era and
then the the do era you know mob Ru
rules and Heaven and Hell are faster
heavier you know yes yeah yeah so um I
think it would be very very difficult to
Define uh new wave of British heavy
metal uh in isolation but by comparison
to what came before and what came later
there was certainly a change that
happened beforehand which I should in
the obum and there was certainly well in
some respects a change that happened
later um which ushered in a whole other
genre of loads of other genres of metal
um eventually
Noam morphed it didn't really morph it
was always been there it just changed we
decided to call it traditional heavy
metal instead in the WAN if you these
days there are mountains of bands
particularly coming out of South America
bizarrely enough um the Met scene in
South America is absolutely on fire at
the moment loads of bands there who
produce not only really good stuff but
you can clearly hear hear the maiden
priest influences on those albums there
really good stuff so what was once the
wum did continue I mean like I said
there was kind of um what would you call
it a mass C event in roughly about 1984
but the idea of what noin was and what
it sounded like influenced by the bands
who did survive that mass Co has
continued and I think you could credibly
say that at least certainly in the UK I
think this probably would have happened
independently in the states anyway but
you could make an argument for uh things
like uh thrash and extreme metal having
been having come out of the Noam scene I
mean if you look they never described
themselves as a noan band but Venom
probably gave rise or you could argue
gave to a lot of what we known so it was
death metal black metal all all that
sort of stuff um there was quite a few
not no not quite a few there were a few
bands who you could probably credibly
describe as as having at least given
rise to the theme of what would lat to
become Thrash as well yeah I mean a lot
of those early thrash bands you look at
who they either like very explicitly
said they were influenced by I mean
think about Metallica and Lars alick's
love for all these these bands at the
time or they'll they'll um you you know
you see in interviews the guitarist will
say yeah I was really influenced by
judis priest or Iron Maiden or um Raven
or um you know some of the other well
Motorhead tank some of these other bands
um so that makes complete sense and
um you know I I was so I was kind of
wondering usually people get quibbl and
they'll well motohead was around before
the new wave of British heavy metal came
out they were influential they're not a
new wave of British heavy metal band
same thing with Judas Priest so I mean
well in another prime example quartz who
tried to get into it but they were a bit
too old you know they'd been around for
a while Tommy Omi was was uh promoting
them so would you include those as would
you say that like you didn't have to be
starting out in this time period you
could have you could have been around
before that but somehow you still fit
into yes okay not so funny enough not so
much Motorhead um I think and this is
something that I think lemy always said
rest in peace lemy um is that he always
described Motorhead as quite simply a
rock band yeah I don't think he even he
even ever described them as a metal band
but anyway um they always stuck to uh
the the the music that they'd always
done in contrast to that yes there were
there were other bands who were around
before quotes like you say but certainly
also Judas priests who right right were
still very much priest but the uh nature
of their music did change a bit and so
they went through what I would describe
as a noin phase ra rather than
um rather than still doing what what
they did I mean yes obviously they were
around long before would you extend that
then like all the way to um Defenders of
the faith yeah okay yeah um I'd say
I'd say Defenders was arguably their
most new album and their best album of
the NOAA yeah interesting and they they
did some weird stuff after Defenders
until until we get
to go ahead I mean point of entry what
what what were you thinking anyway
um until they get to painkiller which
was obviously hey all these young up and
com in BS look what we can do yeah yeah
well a new Drummer right um so you got
to try him out I suppose yes but and
that's funny not to interrupt but uh
because that
was exactly I have a lot of students
that they're priest fans but painkillers
there that's the solo to learn for like
my and that's like the that's their
album and um it it's kind of interesting
that like you know something later on
that was done this generation is and
just like you said look what we can do
and they certainly made a statement on
that you remember when we did like uh
that that episode on best albums of
particular bands and I so we did di Iron
Maiden Judas Priest motohead and then I
think maybe accept was the the other one
that we did so with Judas Priest it
broke down in a very interesting way
painkiller was the number one but only
because it had more people overall
voting for it if you put together
Defenders of the faith um uh screaming
for vengeance sin after sin and um
British
steel um those together got way more
votes than painkiller it just so
happened that painkiller wound up with
the most total votes and it was it was
as if there was a break a generational
break between younger people voting for
painkiller that's the priest that they
know and then the rest of us being like
well painkiller is great but these other
albums you know um better but we were
spread across a bunch of albums whereas
pain killer has this kind of
concentration that I don't think priest
has ever attained before even though
Firepower is a great album you know yeah
um it's it's it's hard to Trump
painkiller in that way yeah I mean as an
anecdote I remember listening to an
interview a radio interview that Rob
hord did this would have been like early
early '90s sometime probably like ' 92
or 93 uh and uh the interviewer whoever
it was asked Rob hord the question I
always remember it the question was
phrased well how do you follow that and
the answer was very
[Laughter]
carefully but yeah to to the point you
made yes AB absolutely I mean like you
say painkiller absolutely fantastic
album completely trashed everything that
the most new metal I don't even
any of the junk that was coming out of
the time with some exceptions but great
album certainly for me though if you
look at some of the much earlier stuff
um British steel Defenders of the faith
screw for
vengeance even even the preum stuff that
that priest did those I would
characterize I mean not so much Rock and
roller because that was really really
early like rock and roller stuff but
certainly Sad Wings and
onwards uh screaming for vengeance and
that period they were far ahead of their
time I think those albums had a real
like ear of almost futurism about them
which you just didn't see from most of
the Bands here's one that's G to come
out of uh left field so rainbow and by
this I don't mean posto rainbow but
those first three albums so if we're
going to extend the new wave of British
heavy metal back to around
75 should rainbow be included in that or
are they still too much within that
Legacy of purple and Sabbath kind of
kind of stuff you know with Gillan going
off on his own and white snake forming
and and all of that that's a tough one
um I think that the first the way I'd
put it is that probably rainbow as well
had the noin period as we could call it
so not so much the first album and
things like man on the Silver Mountain
that that sort of thing no I mean
fantastic tracks notum though um rainbow
Rising we're getting there and oh God
what was it was it long live rock and
roll yeah the album that came after that
at that point yes you could make a very
credible argument for saying that is it
the new album period and there was there
were other bands as well
who outside of or in a different place
at a different time you could you could
more properly describe as or perhaps
equally properly describe as being metal
adjacent and a couple of bands in that
list who are on my list of bands who
should have made it big but didn't
perhaps we'll get R to talking about
them a little bit later but uh yeah yeah
um I think that there was a difference
in in the sort of music that was being
produced that happened somewhere between
1975 and 1980 which even for older old
even for existing established
bands their music became no Al them even
if the band before that and after that
certainly wouldn't is how I put it so
you know now this gets very very
speculative um but Okay so we've got a
scene and part of what's important in a
scene is the interaction between fans
and the the bands uh but bands are also
fans you know yeah and so this this
shift this change in the sound in a
number of different
dimensions I mean so we know that a a
lot of the what we recognize as new wave
of British heavy metal bands are
influenced by these bands that come
before them Black Sabbath Deep Purple um
Budgy UFO the Scorpions all of that sort
of stuff but they're also listening to
each other as they're coming up right
and so like again this is very very
speculative because I don't think
anybody really knows this but let's
speculate
so you know these bands are probably
buying each other's records and hearing
each other and meeting up with each
other and learning from each other as
well right so what's what's your take on
that I I think
almost almost I mean yeah definitely
that unquestionably happened um I think
I mean even even to the extent of
exactly like you say if you're playing
in the metal band if you if you're in a
metal band that hasn't been around for
very long and you're doing all the pub
scenes and you know you're playing in
perhaps in smaller venues got your first
record label you doing that not as a as
a job but as a that's becomes a passion
project at some point doesn't it so yes
that means you're a metal fan so would
you listen to first of all the other
stuff that you can get easily get access
to which means your other contemporary
band so yeah definitely 100% I think
that happened
yeah well um what before we we should
talk about the bands that that didn't
make it but we should do two things
before that and one of them is quite
natural we should talk about like who
who were your you know favorite ones and
and like who are the people that who are
the bands that uh of course made the the
scene in a big way but I also want to
ask about especially as as somebody from
that side of the pond
um a new wave of British heavy metal ban
that became very controversial for
having sold out too much to America
that's de leopard so first two albums
solidly W of British heavy metal they
make it huge Pyromania you know the the
super production on it made it a fun
record um hysteria and we've got Scott
likes hysteria much more than I do which
is a very low bar because I don't like
it at all you know I think the the
tendencies that we saw in
Pyromania um are carried forward too
much and it's it's who knows what what
what should we cassify is not it's not
metal but it's it's something and long
before that though from what I gather
and so you were there at the time um
people in the British Isles were like
that damn deaf leopard you know they had
their start over here they're really
great but they sold out they just they
wanted to be American now look at how
American they are you know so this would
be even like the Pyromania tour what's
what's your take on that I was funny
enough I was goingon to mention exactly
that band um because some people lump
them in with noan bands and some people
refuse to do saying that they're not
they were their really exactly like you
said their really early material was
unquestionably Noam it it it was they
were Lon with NOA bands they played the
same scenes you know they played the the
the same scenes as other NOA bands
however and I think this is something
that the band themselves have
freely not admitted to but have agreed
on was that quite quickly after the
first one or two albums they moved on
from the album it's not so something
that they how can I put this I it's I
don't want to say it's a scene they
didn't want to be associated with but
they had their own Direction and it
wasn't that um I think they very quickly
graduated onto being much more of a kind
of
a glamrock band for one of a better
description yeah yeah they they became
something different I mean in an
analogous way to Venom I mean in their
really really early days uh Venom played
stuff which you could conceivably
considered to be vaguely similar to Mo
album but they had their own ideas and
this is something that what's his name
Kronos and mantis I don't know what
their real names are and I've both said
is that yes in our really really early
days we played similar stuff to other
people but we wanted to do our own thing
it was different to what was going on
those bands were all cool we like their
stuff and perhaps they like ours but
what we wanted to do was uh something
much more aggressive is is the way
they've described it as I understand so
yeah again not in the wob band but yeah
de leopard very much in their really
really early days they were in a wobin
band and very quickly moved away from it
um and I think it's probably a product
of the fact that and some hindsight
comes into this because the the move to
glamrock and to some to a lesser extent
the star of thrash and and death medal
in in the US uh a lot of people who were
huge noram fans view the rise of
glamrock as as having contributed
materially to the the the culling of a
vast number of noin bands that took
place so bands that deliberately went
from being noin bands to glamr are not
viewed favorably amongst certain cohorts
of the fan base well I the Def Leopard
thing I want to point out um so you know
high and dry is my favorite hands down
um I loved Pyromania a lot um but here's
what happened um and I think both of you
know this this um oh who was the who was
the guitarist
uh who was the guitarist uh on high and
drve Pyromania Phil Colin had to come in
and do a solo he did the solo to stage
fright and Phil Colin ended up doing
that
tour and it was the introduction of him
that brought that whole hysteria sound I
think you know he always he always says
you know that was me you know and um
Clark you know uh anytime Vivian
Campbell tried to talk about you know
he's like you know but this is but I
think I think the big
change was the when um Phil Colin went
into the band because if you notice it
kind of kept that direction and really
they they only you know I won't go see
them anymore because they're stuck in
1988 yeah they play the same set you
know and they put out some good records
like you know so some good records along
the way and they even a new album you
you know you want to hear four or five
from the new album they won't do it they
just play all of Hysteria and and I I
don't love hysteria it grew on me but it
was okay but you know I was a high and
dry guy you know and um and and
Pyromania because they kind of invented
that
um what do they call it um kind of Pop
metal where it was like the big choruses
yeah yeah like Rock of Ages they were
kind of like you know they were kind of
doing that but then I I always just
think it's it was the introduction of
Phil Colin that brought it a whole
different direction you know he's just
he came from a glamrock band funny
enough
yeah yeah I think in hindsight that's
that's that's probably definites true
yeah yeah I think they were called girl
he came from oh okay yeah yeah and he he
used to wear make he was he was
Glam you know and that so while we're
talking about like the going glam Lam SL
more American Commercial thing um so
I've I've heard that Raven wound up
getting some FL for that as well I think
it was was it um back to the attack or
the pack is back or forget there's so
many a a in it but um it was the same
sort of thing where they were told well
you kind of need to get with the times I
think it was around
86 um and on and on is on that if I
remember right which is a great song you
know um was there were there other bands
besides de leopard which is the most
notable uh example of this where they
they were new wave of British heavy
metal and then they started going in a a
more let's just call it commercial
Direction and then they R viewed as like
ah you've left the fans
behind that were notable in that
respect not really I mean Raven didn't
commit for anything like the same level
of flack that um Death Leopard did yeah
and they recovered from it too yeah they
did yeah yeah yeah um it's funny kind of
one of two things happened to bands who
survived the uh the great cull of 1984
to or 1983 to 1984 they either stuck to
doing exactly what they'd done before in
terms of this as the music we like to do
we're just going to do this for you know
for the rest of Time band like maid
maiden and Saxon knew exactly what they
were going to do you know this is what
we love and priest to some extent or uh
bands that tried to I say tried
deliberately tried to diversify and move
off into different musical areas and
most of the ones that did that failed
miserably and I was thinking Diamond
Head would be an example of that right
with their third album was Canterbury um
it's a lot softer than yes yeah yeah
yeah there in fact that's a very good
example another band whose early stuff
was unquestionably no ALB who who then
fairly quickly moved in a different
direction I mean we we said earlier that
they had a new wave of British heavy
metal phase rainbow would be another
prime example much softer sound once
once di leaves and Richie Blackmore is
taking it with uh was it jolen Turner
who took over the first album okay
praying mantis was another band oh yeah
yeah again questionably started off as
um Noam how do you describe the latest
stuff Prague maybe irq right yeah maybe
yeah I mean would you say that about
tigers of pantang as
well less so much less so tigers tigers
of pantang were really always uh what
they continued to be they were always
like a metal adjacent heavy rock band
great stuff great music but yeah yeah um
I would personally struggle to lump them
in with
no I think okay so let's let's come back
to the other one that I raised before
we've already mentioned Sachs and Iron
Maiden um Judas Priest motohead um de
leopard for a certain amount of time we
talked a little bit about Raven we've
talked about Venom um who else
like sort of let's call it the the
second tier of bands on the scene which
doesn't mean that they were in any way
bad they were great but they're they're
part of the fabric that that holds it
together who would you say are the bands
that really are quite important in that
respect maybe we'll need to make a
little bit of a distinction between
important and
popular for reasons that we can get into
yeah yeah here's when to start very
important and ended up being not
particularly popular at all Samson why
are they important Bruce Dickinson's
first band right yeah of course leaves
them in Fairly sharp order to front
Maiden I mean they continued for years
afterwards doing stuff which was fairly
good but of course you know the rest of
the world had kind of moved on which is
I think a little bit unfortunate for
them um there was uh Magnum I mean you
might say scen as they have about 400
albums that that that we should struggle
to call them a second tier band but they
were no way as big as maiden or priest
or anything like that but yeah hell of a
good band in their own right and in you
know one of the bands who continued to
do their thing we play Noam and we're
going to play or Noam adjacent heavy
Rock um you know for the for the rest of
the time and with the uh unfortunate
death of their guitar is fairly recently
may not be continuing for much longer
but anyway um yeah Magnum definitely uh
Angel witch were another
one uh great band did some really good
early stuff again in many ways I would
lump them in with the the kind of the
subj of of theatrical sat satanic metal
that came out definitely in the same
vein as bands like witch fighter General
and and and hell and Demon and and that
sort of stuff so yeah um tank were
another band um yeah who went on for
quite a while I mean their early stuff
was really good despite their very
unfortunate um album titles and that
sort of thing yeah
80s yeah yeah and and some stuff with
that you look at these days and think oh
was that really a good album title no it
wasn't well you know it's funny too
because with that one and then the album
artwork on it they don't make sense
together at all no no not in the
slightest at least with Black Sabbath's
born again there's a baby okay it's a
baby devil it kind of makes sense yeah
yeah yeah I don't know I can only
imagine that both the the album title
and the the the artwork for it
originated from some drunk discussion
set at
some yeah a band who's musically very
good um and to some extent I mean God
they would have faced some criticism for
again for their album titles these days
but um a band who probably should have
been bigger than they were because
they're actual Musical and the kind of
uh consistent themes to and and that
sort of thing was uh was good for the
time
uh we talked about tank Holocaust I mean
there was girls school could you really
call them yeah I think you call them a
second rate not second second rate
sounds wrong but um Second Division
band who again did some really good
stuff and for whatever reason were were
never quite as big as perhaps their
talent um should you know there were
some interesting connections later on I
mean girl school was connected with
motohead but there was another band um
rock Goddess that put out just a few
albums um and it was you know one of the
sisters was so young that I think she
was actually breaking the law by being
in the pubs at the time um I think it
was the
drummer but they they kind of yeah
that's true I mean my one of my first
dates was actually being at a bar here
in Milwaukee when I was 14 years old you
know and playing pool but um they you
know girl school and uh Rock got have
swapped out members later on right um
and you know their first album was
pretty good I'd say you know um I mean
we mentioned Diamond Head and so that's
that's kind of a good transition to the
bands that really had a lot of potential
and somehow the stars did not align you
know you mentioned the big culling but I
think some of these bands lost their way
before that yeah they did yeah yeah like
what happened to Angel witch for example
I mean they were viewed as like being
solidly at the center of uh the new wave
of British heavy metal when when the
term got got coined why why do you think
they didn't make it as big as you know
even not necessarily Iron Maiden because
nobody really made it as big as that in
that movement but like let let's use
Saxon as a comparison you know Saxon is
they're not a sec they're sort of like
in between first and second tier you
know yeah yeah yeah the at least tier
two plus I I would put Saxon
yeah what happened to Angel which I'm
not honestly I'm not entirely certain I
don't know whether it was some Calamity
with with a band member or whether they
just didn't get on in terms of the the
musical Direction they wanted to take
things but um it was a real shame
because there is a prime example of a
band who showed tremendous promise uh
and could easily have I mean you could
see uh the way I think their their music
was developing that they could have
developed uh into all I mean potentially
in all sorts of different different
directions which would have could well
have taken them very far in terms of
popularity but yeah I I don't know why I
don't know why I don't know whether it
was the fact that for whatever reason
they they just never got a the correct
size of record deal or whether or
whether time passed them by and maybe
some some of their fan base at least had
kind of moved on to other things that's
interesting I mean so there's the a
number of different factors you're
you're bringing up one is whether you
can get a band to really effectively gel
you know I mean there were some bands
where it was like a rotating uh door of
of bands there might just be yeah there
just might be one core guy who who stays
there or you lose one really key band
member and it's just curtain after yeah
like I'll mention a band that's not
considered new wave of British heavy
metal and they shouldn't because they're
American but they were often talked
about a lot which is Riot um you know
and those first three albums Rock City
Narita and um I'm blanking on the name
of the third one but it's the one that's
got swords and Tequila on it really
great stuff but they lose their singer
and they're never the same after that
yeah here's another example of a
non-british pent who 100% no Alum armed
Saint oh oh very interesting I I was
that wasn't the one I was thinking you
would bring up yeah but that's good make
the case if if they were I mean just
list listen to their musical styles
their musical
things plunk them somewhere in Britain
and they would 100% be right in the
middle of the early Noam scene no
question about that because I mean even
even now the stuff they're doing now is
very I don't want to use the word
similar but thematically and in
construction and that sort of thing
quite similar to the stuff that men are
doing at the moment would I mean would
you say that sirth angle
would fit like if you'd taken them out
of LA and plunk them into Britain would
they have been a new wave of British
heavy metal
band I me certainly certainly in the
early days yeah probably yeah they proba
would been yeah yeah yeah who who else
would you I mean i' I've been kind of
kicking this idea around of new wave of
British heavy metal bands that weren't
actually British who else would you
include in
there
are there any others that come to mind
like would loudness possibly
be in that that that genre even though
they're way over in
Japan yeah yeah I think you can make a
good case for that I mean again in terms
of I mean I'm not an expert on this on
on this sort of thing Scott you'll know
much more about this than I will but in
terms of the their kind of like what
comes across has been their playing
techniques in music and and in terms of
thematics and all that sort of thing
yeah AB absolutely no of just happened
to be in a different place at the time
yeah yeah are there are there any that
you can think of Scott where you're like
yeah
this not technically British but they
could fit in
there you know there's always a
um and and they'll deny it
but like Blue Oyster Cult oh yes because
interesting absolutely I mean I mean not
so much the latest stuff but of the
period right of the time yeah if we if
we want to go between like 77 and 83 884
for example okay and that's a cut off
point with them yeah yeah I mean look at
what happens on I mean all these like
best rock compilation album Number
2372 what do you find you get Run to the
Hills Paranoid by Black Sabbath and
always Don't Fear the Reaper Oyster Cult
thematically very similar so yeah I mean
again I think I think had Noam continued
and if we'd want to Blue Oyster cut in
with them that that we might think of
them as potentially progressing in a
slightly heavier Direction than they did
but I mean that could have easily have
happened so yeah in terms of the the
very early original stuff yeah
absolutely yeah yeah they they heavier
stuff Eric Bloom sang but um only the
stuff that buck sang like Reaper made it
on the radio and I guess answer is Eric
Bloom didn't have a voice for radio you
know he's more like you know he sang he
e sang the heavier Tunes yes yeah well
you know that is a great segue into uh
something else so growing up here in the
Midwest a lot of these bands even the
big ones like Iron Maiden who you know
attained a worldwide status we wouldn't
really hear them much on the radio I
mean there could be like metal shows
that would play really late at night um
I mean there were some exceptions you'd
hear the Scorpions you'd hear um um
some other you know metal bands as well
but you know judis priest iron maid in
Motorhead you weren't going to hear them
at all and you certainly weren't going
to hear Saxon or Raven or you know these
these other new wave of British heavy
metal bands what was it like in Britain
were they getting airplay much in any
venue or was it mostly you'd get to hear
him because your friends had an album or
you'd go to the pub and you'd hear him
or or things like that I can't remember
when this started but yes there was uh
the BBC in a moment of probably from
their perspective regrettable Clarity on
a on a Friday not because I mean less
diverse digression a little bit this is
a super stuffy traditionalist
organization in the early 80s I mean
heavy metal good Lord we can't have that
satanic nonsense on the radio here don't
you know we're British
any at some point at some point uh the
BBC in a moment of drastic Enlightenment
introduced a rock show on a Friday or
did it start on a Thursday anyway can't
remember one night a week had a two-hour
slot um it was Friday it was called the
Friday Rock show with a uh produc um a
the person presenting the show was a
chat by name of Tommy Vance um who later
went to America when the BBC reverted to
standing and canceled it but um yeah so
you could listen to heavy metal and
surprisingly internationally as well
because Tommy Vance was obviously an an
actual heavy metal fanatic same as
everybody listening to the show so um he
would certainly make the effort to to
get like I mean you you get him playing
tracks from import uh import discs and
all that sort of thing from all around
the world so that was really by and
large one of the the the main ways to
expose yourself to music from other
countries until until the really the
rise of what we might describe as Proto
thrash and death metal at that point a
lot of I mean Metallica was everywhere
um yeah later uh I mean later on guns of
roses Mega Death Slayer and lots of lots
of other bands but in the really early
days uh much less so
yeah interesting yeah go we we have
eventually had MTV uh what was it called
The Headbangers ball Headbangers ball
well you know they did that originally
because there were so many requests that
were coming in for metal stuff that they
were like well we can't be doing metal
all the time we'll coordin it off over
here yeah you but you had to have you
had to have a video and so I think that
really kept a lot of the you know lower
level bands
out yeah even bands like Iron Maiden
didn't have a lot of videos at the time
no and it appears that a lot of their
videos were just kind of done at that
time because they're like well people
want videos let's throw CRA together
yeah yeah yeah yeah I think I mean this
may be a bit contentious but um as I
understand it MTV in particular were
were
famously antagonistic towards IR am
Maiden for reasons which supp pass my
understanding huh I wonder why I mean I
don't know whether it's with the same
reason that they never got in the radio
I mean they did but I mean would you
play Run to the Hills seven trillion
times I mean it's a great song but come
on do other stuff and the reason Maiden
never really got a time and this is
something that H who was it said in an
interview it might have been nickel um
was that because they tended to do
longer songs due to the themes of their
songs um their songs tended to be too
long to play on a radio station because
you you want to do like 50 500 songs
during a day or whatever um so that all
the music Publishers get equal air time
and Maiden never let them do that so
they never got a decent amount of air
time which is part of the reason why
they were always they've always been so
good to their fans because they
recognize word of mouth and people going
around to their mates houses and the
local pub that all you know listening on
the occasional Friday night on between
10: and midnight or some ridiculous time
that the Friday Rock show was on this is
the only way that we're going to get
more fans so in in exchange for that we
turn up and do a you know try to put on
a professional performance
yeah but yeah um music videos though um
I think probably the only only Maiden
music videos I've ever seen were were
kind of accidents probably or like you
said Chuck Chucks together because we've
got to do a video at some point yeah get
some stock footage I mean Run to the
Hills is a great example of that
right Wasted Years kind of right
yeah oh my gosh I mean it's basically
just just you've got shots of the band
playing and then you've got some footage
that may or may not have
anything yeah yeah I mean I suppose the
one exception to that is uh is the
prisoner right which is based on the TV
show and this is this is something that
Rod Smallwood commented on in an
interview that he did at some point was
that they uh phoned up the people who
the producers of the TV show The
Prisoner and and and said can we do a
video about it because you know can we
do a song about it with a video and the
the producers of of the TV show said who
were you again I maiden and the response
was apparently just do it so they did um
which is why which is why the video I'm
not sure if he uses official segments
from the TV show but I mean it's
blatantly obvious what it is it's
completely in line thematically with the
song as opposed to almost all their
other videos which have got nothing to
do with well the song's about you know
exactly I mean it's kind of a cool story
that they went along with it because of
course the other one that comes to mind
is yeah and asking Frank Herbert and him
saying screw you I don't like your
crap wait what did you I I missed that
part so you know to tame a land is based
on the novel um Dune by Frank Herbert
and they actually asked him and he he
he's not a fan of heavy metals so he
said absolutely not so they had to call
it something different because they were
just gonna call it Dune you know yeah oh
my God and speak of a long song I think
that one top seven minutes long it's got
all these key changes and yeah yeah yeah
one of my favorites actually from the
album but yeah yeah let's come back to
um something that we haven't completely
exhausted so so bands that really had a
lot of potential and I mean some of them
have gotten back together later on and
done some some good stuff I was thinking
um Jaguar is an example of that that a
crazy album is really really good but
somehow things didn't come together
right and they have put out some or no
power games acts crazy as the song um
album art is terrible of course which
might have been a problem it's like a
chess board with all sorts of weird crap
on it you know I I don't know who they
got to do all these these these album
art things back then but I think it was
just finding art artist
exactly some proverbial starving artist
but they've but they' put out stuff
subsequently in the 2010s that's really
really good and I don't know how much of
the original makeup of the band is still
there but I think we can say that about
quite a few of these bands that had
potential back then um didn't make it
because the record deal didn't go
through or the manager was stealing the
money or was somebody's uncle or you
know Tokyo blade is another I think
prime example of that who else would you
say is um worth you know worth looking
at in that respect um there's there's
actually three bands that I want to
mention and I've actually I've actually
bought some props along I've got a stack
of CDs here so um the first one first
one's a band called Pagan alter oh yeah
I don't know them so Pagan alter they
they started off back in the in probably
mid to late s and into the very early '
80s they weren't I suppose now you
struggle to call them a metal band they
were much more kind of like uh hard rock
metal adjacent however if you listen to
the stuff that I mean they they they
have produced several albums but it's
all been 30 35 40 years after they first
they were first together as a band and
if you listen to it now the the stuff
they've done since it's very um
doomy almost like some albums of Black
Sabbath or or um well or witchfinder
general witch finder General yeah
definitely um they unfortunately their
original lead singer passed away in in
the last year or two so I mean they've
got a new lead singer but um yeah a band
that should have been way bigger than
they were back in the day because it was
very much Proto Doom um back then
although no actually no no no no I'm
completely wrong talking nonsense not
Proto Doom what they the stuff they
ended up producing was exactly the same
sort of
uh theatrical Satanist stroke pigan
medal as bands like Wich fun in general
definitely that sort of gen yeah in a
very similar vein a band called
hell who've had two albums one of them
is called human remains and the other
one is called Curson chapter who had a
an incredibly unfortunate early history
in the early 80s been everything that
could have gone wrong for them basically
did go wrong for them uh which led to
them never producing ing any albums back
back in the day I mean this one in
particular uh human remains as I
understand it are stuff that they'd
actually written and rehearsed but never
recorded back in the early 80s and again
very very super talented band easily no
Alum um you put that album back in
probably 1982 or '93 and they uh what
should have deserves to have been as
equally popular as the likes of M or
Saxon or priest they were really really
good um and now have come out with their
own modern album which is called curon
chapter uh
with Andy snoep on guitar really
interesting Andy sneep gets everywhere
yeah I suppose he does to to you know
all sorts of bands but really showcases
not only his his many in VAR abilities
as a producer but also as a guitarist
that guy is really talented really
talented we got we got to see him with
with priest here several times in
Milwaukee and I'm I'm actually very
happy with him and Richie Falkner as
replacing KK Downing and and Glenn
Tipton you know such energy that they
both bring to it you know and the solos
they don't make any mistakes either of
those guys no to be fair I think
something that really helps is that
certainly from all the like interviews
and talks that I've done it it would
appear that Rob howford actually gets on
really well with both of them so you you
do get that the of gels together and you
get better music as a result of that
yeah um the this is going to sound like
a trick question the third band I wanted
to mention as having never caught a
break is a band called Iron Maiden at
which point everyone thinks what the
hell are you talking about is that is
that maybe a clone of the the Iron
Maiden we know or not a clone there were
another band called Iron Maiden oh
really who had an album way back in the
day called Maiden Journey um again kind
of a this this States back to I mean I
guess you could claim that they were
really preum because this was like 75 I
want to say out there abouts but um very
much a Proto Doom band who you could
easily see had they progressed any
further um developing into either Noam
or or one of the kind of like theatrical
doomy type PS like hell and and which
one in general that sort of thing the
real shame that they never got a break
because what they did produce their one
and only album I mean they really
talented really talented had they
managed to make it though the Iron
Maiden that we know would had have
changed their name and who knows what
that would have led who knows what
history would have led to Mark says
hell's live shows are great at least as
SE I've seen YouTube yeah look look him
up on look him up on YouTube definitely
agree with that yeah excellent as uh um
Pig and aler also put on a really good
live show oh yeah this is going to be a
first but I got to get my plug or my or
I'm going to leave this session my
computer's going to die but I can hear
you okay well I so I have a bit of a uh
off-the-wall uh question to see if
you've got any answers to it I I know I
brought it up to you earlier um and this
is just complete trivia
silliness um so Trifecta titles where
the name of the band is the name of
their debut album and they also have a
song like that so Iron Maiden right the
the song Iron Maiden really great on the
the album Iron Maiden and Angel Witch is
pretty famous for that as well you know
I could actually hear it in my head you
know you're an angel witch you're an
angel witch it's quite good you know um
and then I the other day I came across
another example a band called cloven
hoof that actually has an album cloven
hoof and a song cloven hoof which is
which is quite good and I think solidly
within the new wave of British heavy
metal are there any others that come to
mind
where and you know it's kind of weird
that you know You' think this is a
little bit too much of the name isn't it
but it it works in some cases are there
any others that you can think of the
only other one I could think of it
unfortunately I say it's not unfortunate
because they're a damn fine band but the
only other one I could think of aren't
in a hobin band the only other one I
could think of is of course Metal Church
oh right right oh how we forget Metal
Church chur Church you time was
right we were on that subject that's a
good one yeah great band there I mean
again worth pointing out points out
Black Sabbath yes of course black not
new wave of British heavy metal but yeah
that's that's a band that works again
Metal Church if you go really we I mean
not not even um sort of hear the
children playing and that area but if
you go really back to their first stuff
you could conceivably lump that in with
having a kind of a noish sound as well
before they they put the finger on the
accelerator so to speak yeah usually
they get portrayed as a thrash band but
yeah the early stuff isn't really thrash
is it yeah I mean you you I suppose I me
we could end argue about you know Sub
sub genres and Sub sub categorizations
endlessly but I think you could uh you
could probably say that they really
early stuff while being verging on Proto
speed metal Proto thrash had a definite
Noam influence stroke characteristic in
it same actually if you go right back to
the start the really early Slayer stuff
had new new obum
influences okay
yeah I mean it's it's it's good to point
this stuff out because I think a lot of
times people are looking backwards as if
these categories are very nicely defined
and you can like draw this this line
here and stuff like that and they forget
how
sloppy maybe that's the wrong word but
permeable these these categories were I
I remember reading an early interview
with Kronos from Venom where he's asked
what kind of metal do you
play and he lists like the I think they
were asking him do you play speed metal
and he was like we play Power medal we
play Black medal we play and it was like
five different categories and you know
you think about what counts as power
metal today and you're like well no this
is not power metal at all I mean power
metal would at least be well produced
you know and it would guitar solos that
that are really quite nice and and you
know sort of harmonic nature to it but
that's because you know they're using
the word in such a different way 10 20
years down the line and I think a lot of
you know so actually let me ask you when
when when you would
categorize things back in the day uh um
how how did people in the new wave of
British heavy metal who are fans of it
how did they talk about it did they use
these sorts of terms to well if you like
this this is also similar to this
because it's XYZ kind of metal or would
you be more loose in the terminology
that that kind of C categorical
descriptor never existed I mean okay you
you could date the the Inception of the
phrase new wave of British heavy metal
to that I forget what magazine it was in
that adal in 1979 use the term Noam
until much much later uh it was just
metal but you're talking about uh Venom
saying yeah you know we we played this
type of metal this type of metal this
type of metal you could I mean if you're
going to be a little bit reductionist
about it you could add the phrase
because we invented them all to that you
know but I think that genuinely that
does go back to the point about bands
listening to each other so you get that
cross pollination of different themes
and and even even like playing Styles I
mean if you're a guitarist you you talk
to somebody you meet in the bar because
you played in a gig at the same place
and of course you swap ideas over a few
drinks Mark has a very interesting
question here that I'd like to get both
Scott and kon's take out and I actually
have a story too that I'll I'll throw in
there very quickly what do you think of
Metallica's covers of new wave of
British heavy metal songs and so the
story I'll tell very very quickly my
oldest child
cat is a huge fan of metal has been
since she was a kid because I played it
in the car she was driving around and um
we were on a trip together it's about
four or five years back and I played for
her both um Diamond heads am I evil and
Metallica's am I evil and at the time
she was playing my old bass and and you
know studying uh music and things like
that and I was like okay so which of
these is actually better and she gave
the right answer which is Diamond heads
and she was able to explain why
Metallica is heavier right it's it's got
more of what we would typically assoc
more features that we typically
associate with heavy metal that's a
great cover but Diamond heads is by some
standards better and and it was really
cool that she could articulate to me
what she thought made it better so let
me let me throw this question doesn't
have to be am I evil what do you think
of Metallica covers of new wave of
British heavy metal
songs it's hard for me to dissociate uh
my love of no and from my opinion of
Metallica As a band uh they how can I
put this I think some they they have
done very talented reproductions of some
of those songs okay I don't
think how can I put this there are very
very few covers
which I've ever liked and this goes for
any genre of music or any type of metal
by any band on behalf of any other other
metal band I don't think covers really
are a very good idea frankly but are
they good they they they're done in a
very talented way they're obviously well
played because the guys in Metallica are
very talented do I prefer them more The
Originals no no I
don't I should actually kick another one
to you that's on Garage Days Revisited
because you're Welsh Bud's bread
fan right yeah yeah yeah yeah Budgy were
great P very very very good band and do
I like that yeah I do I mean metal In
fairness to them In fairness to them yes
I will admit they did something good
since the Black
Album it was a good track a good cover
what about you Scott what do you
think you know I I remember when that uh
when Garage Days came out
um of course me being a big blue oyster
cold head you
know I thought you know at the time I
just felt they they butchered astronomy
because that's
but I also gained respect because that
was a deep cut to to select you know I
was like okay well they didn't go for
the easy you
know I that's not fair to say they I
hope I didn't say they they they
butchered it I just
I like the original or like the the live
version from um Some Enchanted Evening
that to me is the tune I didn't I didn't
really enjoy the Metallica version of a
lot of the tunes um and I'll agree it's
like yes they're good players but it's
not always about technically doing it or
you know they were trying to do it in
their own way which is cool you know
hence the the the the um hence the album
Nam garage days but
I I didn't really I think I gave that
album a couple
listens and um and decided it was fun it
was cool it was probably fun for them to
do but it's not like I said well I got
to start listening to this version now I
mean I guess I would put it no
disrespect to Metallica but I just you
know yeah you know it it's interesting
we talked about this before when we had
um a session on metal covers so Diamond
Head has said well you know Metallica
really did us a favor by covering Ami
eval because that has kept us you know
earning money all these years but
there's also that famous incident of
diamond had going up on stage to play
with Metallica and people them off stage
because they thought that they were
stealing Metallica's song because they
didn't know enough about where had it
had actually originated from um and so
did they in a in a way did a favor but
also kind of did some damage by covering
these songs I mean people probably went
and listen to Budgy more after Metallica
covered Red fan um because Budgy was
fairly obscure over here in the states
I'm sure in England they they certainly
weren't you know definitely not in Wales
but um you know so it's it's kind of
taking with one hand and and giving with
the other right
uh yeah I mean that that is true I mean
I got to be honest I've probably been a
little bit unfair to the concept of of
of cover tracks an entire compilation
album of cover tracks which I actually
really enjoyed including a very well
done One by Metallica uh was the tribute
album uh that was created after Dio past
away for the cancer charity that he was
a member of that's got some really good
material on it is well worth it I can't
remember what it's
called wow cop of it here somewhere but
yeah very good um I have to take a look
at that they covers of all sorts of
different tracks that do did both his
solo stuff um his stuff with rainbow and
his stuff with Black Sabbath very very
good um to answer Mark's question there
about um El's selection for the Noam
collection 79 Revisited Al yeah the guy
picked some really good tracks for that
I'm looking at it right now I've never
actually listened to it but yeah re
reading down the list there's a lot in
here where you're like yeah this is if I
had to pick a song this is this is
definitely one of them like diamond
heads helpless rather than am I eval y
um oh wow there's one I haven't heard in
a long long time is fight with the devil
Hollow ground
wow yeah there there's a couple in there
where it's kind of obvious like they
they get included in every anth ology
girl schools demolition
boys
um motorcycle man sax okay that you know
kind of tracks what the thing I really
like about L his choices that he he's
put on this album with some exceptions I
mean yes with some exceptions but there
are lots of things on there where you
certainly wouldn't pick that particular
Track by that particular band as being
on you know the next pointless
compilation album I mean Sanctuary by
Maiden for example that never gets
played anywhere that's never been part
of of any compilation of them so yeah
interesting choice yeah or um Angel do
by Venom's another one yeah yeah that's
that's one that really catches your eye
um and then there was another one that I
that I I saw in there that was like yeah
this Cap City PR Samson's vice
versa that's a slow softer track except
for the parts where it it gets hard you
know they actually did produce a video
for it which is kind of a goofy thing I
didn't know that interesting oh yeah you
you should check it out it's so
backstory is um it's not quite a rock
opera thing but they they produced a
really cheesy typically
1980s kind of
um story thing with you know um weird
things happening and fights and stuff
like that and I guess there were two s
that were supposed to be in it uh
sandwiched with each other so there's a
constant story that goes through both of
them and they made very few videos this
is one of the videos that they
made but yeah it's I mean I think it's
pretty good and de leopard get your
rocks off
yeah so yeah good compilation Al
them it would be interesting to I mean
we could do this some other time talk
about other key compilation albums I got
to know quite a few new wave of British
heavy metal bands because of something
that was uh produced and then
immediately found its way into the
Bargain Bin at um department stores here
in the United States that was metal
killer collection
so it was thanks to them that I found
out about tank uh they had uh run like
hell on there uh they had girl schools
demolition boys they they had a few
stinkers in there as well that where
you're like I'm not sure this is metal
but a lot of it was was really quite
good that's a very interesting question
actually because I suppose the question
is in if you're going to do a
compilation album either only involving
one band or involving like a a single
genre compilation album how do you do it
so that you can both include some really
interesting material but also not be
identical to the last 50 compilation
albums so yeah that that'd be an
interesting thing did have to think
about I've thought about you know list
making and so we're all you know kind of
older guys now at this point uh
fortunate enough to have like lived
through the formative years I mean we
were all too young to like be going to
concerts uh with with some of the bands
in the early 70s I mean I was born in in
1970 um so obviously I wasn't going to
see Black Sabbath or deep purple back
that but we you know we came up in the
late 70s early 80s all I think all of us
were fortunate enough as you were
mentioning Ken to have older friends or
you know family members who could clue
us into this cool stuff that was was out
there and um you know we could think
about I'm not saying we have like a
moral duty or something like that but we
could think about the project of so if
we want to teach a younger generation
about this sort of stuff because they're
looking at it from a very very different
perspective that's informed by streaming
and Wikipedia and YouTube videos and
stuff like that they didn't have access
to the kind of network and pre- internet
um era that that we had and going out to
oftentimes see music at at at live
venues um it's an interesting exercise
to think about what would we produce
almost as like here's your cultural
education materials for younger people
you want to know about the new wave of
British heavy metal all right here's 40
tracks
this will not just give you the popular
stuff or as you were saying Ken the
stuff that's on every single compilation
album this will give you a sense of what
it was like but also give you like
breadcrumbs where to go next you know
yeah not necessarily the most uh the
most popular stuff but what you might
consider to be the most important from
an influence perspective and that's I
always say that um two points and you
bring up a really good point about where
we are with
technology um actually let's just go
with that one so I'm finding you know I
I work with 18 to 21 year olds teaching
at
Berkeley and something in the last five
six years has become kind of scary um so
you know we all remember at the
beginning of this well we'll have access
to everything we'll know so much more
there'll be so much more
literate um
and I've done this exercise now where
I'll take a student who's come to
Berkeley as a guitar principal Rock
right and I'll start I'll look at uh the
student and I'll run down a list like
this do you know who Peter Frampton is
no who's the guitarist for you too I
don't
know and then I'll continue on a list
like this and you know look even when I
was coming up with that I I I knew who
Scotty Moore was you know from uh
Elvis's band even though that wasn't my
thing I was in but like I knew who
Lawrence Welk was cuz my grandpa watched
it and you know like we knew all this
stuff
about you know what we did just because
we traded records and it's fascinating
that we knew so much more back then so I
go through this whole list and they say
no and then I say how long have you been
here and some of them will say four
semesters that's 2 years years and I'll
say can you name an artist in Boston
that's not associated with Berkeley
no so I said so I'm saying you mean to
tell me you're here and you're not out
in the the clubs meeting people seeing
people you know um and I think with and
then I'm I'm like well who do you listen
to and as far as rock guitars they all
listen to the same three people and
that's it and you know it's like well
they have the you might like this but
they have to actively click on you might
like this to discover something and I've
even gone to the point where I'll say
you have to listen to this one album
this week and back in the day we'd have
to get in our car and drive to the
record store find who had it in stock
right and um next week did you listen to
it
no and um you know it's kind of scary
and interesting that pre- internet we
were exposed to so much
more you know it's the mindset so this
idea of a compilation you know it's kind
of like with the younger generation I
don't think they'd even listen to it um
I mean it's not that they're all like
that some of them have parents that
listen to it as they grew up but it's
kind of a thing how we're talking about
we started this discussion off by
talking about you know paying their dues
and then your friend calling you the day
and going to the show and you know it
was really our pleasure to be there to
listen to the music or it our pleasure
to like get the last copy of the new
Deep Purple you know when perfect
strangers came out or whatever
and it's kind it's kind of like this
conversation we're H we're having right
now is is kind of sad because you won't
you don't hear people talking like that
that are coming up now you know they're
more want to be on Tik Tok or they want
to um they want insta gratification
so you know it's really interesting
that I I think just this thing would be
fascinating for them to watch if they
had the attention span because the
stories Ken Ken is saying um yeah yeah I
think there's there's a wider point
there about how to learn about different
cultures you I mean if you want to study
a different and it doesn't matter what
it is it could be rock or or mods or or
you know heavy metal or or being an
opera fan could be whatever right uh you
can read about it in a book you can
watch documentaries about it which will
only take take you so far if you really
want to learn about it you have to
immerse yourself in it yes that's how
you get a proper full picture of what of
what the particular culture is about I
mean do you think so we'd be going
Upstream in this but do you think that
you could say that there is some
potential that the internet has provided
us with I mean look at the the those of
us me and Scott are over here in the
states Ken you're over there on the
other side of the Atlantic Mark is
participating from down in South Africa
and we could have you know viewers
potentially down the line from anywhere
all over the world who say oh yeah yeah
that there's some good points being made
there um maybe you know maybe virtual
communities provide us with for those
who are interested for those who can
figure out where to find them ways of
having that that not quite immersion
right because you're never fully
immersed virtually um still go ahead you
say that but something that can I mean
let's take that example somebody watches
this this video I don't know four years
down the line who who lives in in Poland
or or Japan or wherever it doesn't
matter where and things it's really cool
this sounds really interesting what I'm
going to go and do is find my local
community and immerse myself there that
would be a great way to find different
different different resources different
people you know places bands the list
goes on yeah well there is a local
community though I mean I mean if that
was part of the problem for us growing
up way out in the sticks you know you
couldn't go to the local pub and hear a
ban because there wasn't any local
pub U and I and I think a lot of people
are still kind of stuck living in
situations like that not necessarily
because they're in the countryside but
they could be in a big city and they
just there isn't any there isn't a
population of people interested in
classic metal you know no Poland that's
not going to be a problem I gather you
know they seem to be quite into it yeah
and as he remark too like in South
America boy it seems like there's a lot
of resources for it there too yeah do uh
a couple I mean there there's probably
loads of them but there's a few uh
YouTube channels who I follow who who
focus on traditional heavy metal bands
what we would call noin bands but mon
ones and there are some absolutely cra
in bands coming out of South America at
the
moment the traditional medal scene in
South America is apparently absolutely
on fire well withth researching some
really really cracking
albums Mark has a really interesting
question there are a lot of channels on
YouTube that are dedicated to archiving
records singles EPS LPS of traditional
metal bands from the 70s to 90s some are
incredibly obscure what's your take on
that is it copyright infringement or
piracy or important in preserving these
songs which otherwise which might not be
otherwise preserved cultural
preservation is what that is to my mind
I I mean if there is any copyright
infringement it's probably a lot of
these bands don't exist anymore and some
of the members are dead so I don't think
it makes any difference I was able to
learn about a lot of the bands that I
never even you know had an inkling about
uh through two main things one was
Pandora
because uh when Pandora first came out
using the musical Genome Project they
would say okay you like this band you're
probably GNA like this band and I'd
never heard of them but I'd hear them
and then I'd be like holy [__] this is
great stuff but then YouTube was an
absolute godsend even for bands that are
still around like if you want to hear
tanks honor and blood you cannot do so
on Apple music except for a few songs I
I think there's maybe a dispute about
royalties or something something going
on so they just kind of like put it all
off on the side but you can find the
whole album on YouTube and listen to it
you know an album that at one time I
paid
for I already paid my my dues and and I
think that um the people that are out
there you know so like another two two
other uh new wave of British heavy metal
bands that didn't really make it whose
whose stuff is quite good Legend and
Mithra um I would never have suspected
they existed were it not for YouTube and
back then YouTube's algorithm
recommending those to me because I think
I'd listened to something by Diamond
Head or yeah some other band yeah Scott
you're in the music business what do you
think yeah well as far
as stuff being on YouTube um it comes
down to who owns the publishing and the
songwriters now a lot of these bands
don't own their albums anymore yeah so
you might see bands like remember when
great white redid their first album
album they re-recorded it because the
record company owned it now the record
company could do whatever they want with
it so they could put it on streaming
they could put it and yes you know but
you know unfortunately when you do that
you're not being paid proper sync
licensing or anything like that um so
but you'll see I think Pages Like
official band Pages where they'll have
their music up like
and I can tell you as somebody who's
uploaded um stuff that I've taken at
concerts that YouTube is getting
incredibly sophisticated so I'll just
give you one example Michael schner
group um we saw them here in Milwaukee
recently and you know I had my phone so
I video recorded a few songs from them
you know lights out you're not going to
miss that right and I uploaded it into
another Channel which is just called
heavy metal philosopher which it you
know I haven't actually released it and
as soon as I uploaded it and as soon as
the upload was done it got copyright
flagged but it wasn't we're we're not
going to let you have this here it was
instead the artist already has said it's
okay to have this in there because the
artist will make the money on any sort
of advertising Revenue right but it knew
that it was a lot so it was a live
performance so it's not the same thing
as the album but it's recognizable
enough that they're like okay this is
Michael shner group um lights out and
you know maybe he's sharing it with UFO
I don't I don't know um because did you
type did you type the title
No nope it was a your recognition that
exactly yeah and so if it's that
sophisticated right now think about what
it'll be like in 10 years because that's
that's the the workaround for people you
know like sometimes when you listen to
music it's it's it's a little it's a
little Sharp yeah well they speed it up
and do the do a little so because it
won't recognize it I've heard podcast
people doing that where they they um the
metal podcast things right they'll right
do it at a slightly higher speed you
know and I guess that's to evade that as
well now interestingly I've uploaded um
me playing banjo and singing some old
videos that I had from 12 years ago and
YouTube doesn't flag those at all
one of them is like a Johnny Cash song
and other is a cracker song I just did a
Motorhead one today but I guess that
what I do is uh unrecognizable to the
algorithm as a cover of something that's
legally owned by somebody else yeah
that's that's the the the live one
surprises me because you know it has to
be it like if you if you hold up your
phone right like what is this I'm
listening to yeah it's if it's a live
version not on a live album it'll say I
don't know but if it is on a live album
it like catches exactly yeah yeah so I
that's kind of
curious I know like Keith Jarrett and
Herby Hancock whoever owns their stuff
I've done transcriptions where I play
along with the album like a minute of it
and I'll put it up and then they'll like
take it down and then I just argue it's
for educational purposes which it is I'm
doing a small bit here's a transcription
here's what you can learn from it yeah
it's it's it's funny how they even with
me playing on top of it you know it's
like it's it is pretty I mean that's
that could be a good thing in some ways
but um yeah I mean this is a really
important topic um I think Ken is is
completely right that this is this
should be interpreted as cultural
heritage that should belong to all of us
if we want it but unfortunately these
you know these big companies that own
the the cataloges you know they want to
make their money and and
restrict it and I and I suppose you
could say with with a few bands the ones
who really never made it they're
probably not in the yeah how do you even
access that material does it even exist
anymore I mean even like uh I mean I've
got it's not here because it's in a
secure location I have an original
pressing of Maiden soundhouse tapes from
79 on record and I looked it up the
other day they're worth absurd amounts
of money which is why it's in Secure
Storage but anyway the point is is that
even going way back things like vinyl
pressings uh and tapes those that Medium
has a lifespan so there is there's
mountains of of some really original
stuff I mean stuff that that ought to be
recorded out there that is eventually
going to be lost unless it can be
properly archived and digitized yeah um
that's something that that I think that
uh things like copyright strikes in that
um is potentially very detrimental to
ban has made a very sensible decision
going towards that I mean I remember
back in the day buying Maiden records
and CDs when they were signed to Emi if
you look at the back of a maiden CD now
all the music is owned by Iron Maiden
Holdings Incorporated oh interesting
they're all they've bought their their
music back from the Publishers
effectively as I understand or they held
on to their publishing which was smart
which is hard to do yeah yeah yeah I
mean they had Rod Smallwood you know and
Steve Harris is a brilliant guy too on
the back end as well which gives them a
huge advantage over so many other bands
like I don't think Judas Priest they
probably don't own all of their own
stuff right no I don't think they do
yeah you know that's a good that's a
really good question um yeah there's
stories of like Joanie Mitchell what who
was she signed to in the early 80s oh
geffin and she went to David geffin and
said you aren't doing anything with
these tapes let me have them and and
he's like no I own them she's like but
they're out of print like just and she
talked them into handing over the tapes
but that's a rare case because he was
just he had him on Ice she she's like at
least put him out or I'll put him out
well and there and there's so many cases
I mean going all the way back into the
late 70s where the record companies
would have some stuff from a band and
then they would release it and sometimes
the band wouldn't even know until hit
the record
stores yes yeah yeah and usually they
wouldn't see any any money from it
either that's yeah that's that's tough
and now it's worse than ever of course
people you know people are willing to
give it away for free um but that's a
whole other subject um yeah and we oh go
ahead I'm just going to say last point
then here's the potential loss though
that one record that that band recorded
back in 79 or whatever that got one
release and then the band disbanded and
went there separate ways that record was
never released again but 50 years later
some kid listens to that record and
thinks this is genius I'm going to be a
rock guitarist and then suddenly you get
some huge incredibly successful Mega
band because of that one influence that
came from listening to that thing which
would otherwise be at the risk of being
forgotten about right exactly that's
that's the same example like you put it
out of print there's no way to find it
there's no way to know it exist it
exists you know that's very different
from somebody that's making music and
finished it today and then just started
paying people thousands of dollars to
give it away so they get exposure that
it's very it's a very different thing
archiving and uh and all that it's a
very I I think it's important as well
you know um being able to find something
uh obscure you know and I think um when
YouTube was first coming out before it
got bought out by Google and turned into
the huge uh you know company that it is
today I think that's what a lot of
people were doing it when they were
playing their album and then uploading a
little bit of album art and putting the
time signatures in for these obscure
bands they they they thought they were
just simply archiving it yeah and they
you know YouTube was set up well for
that sort of thing um it's it's no
longer quite so hospitable to that I
guess you could say but there there's
still all that stuff out there it hasn't
been scoured from YouTube yet
thankfully yeah I don't think yeah I I
think it's yeah the live stuff I mean it
can be I understand when the bands well
especially comedians don't want you
recording their shows because you know
you tend to take less risks then you
tend to you know you have a special show
that New York hasn't seen yet but you
know it's almost like I I wish like
bands would more bands would release
like oh here we we found some tapes from
the from the this tour and we're going
to release them you know yeah they were
recorded it didn't take an investment to
make it and you know sell it as a
download or whatever it be be something
I'd be very interested in because you
ever think of like I would love to hear
these songs live but I was never able to
and then well we do have those tapes in
the archives and they're just sitting
there and that' be kind of cool like you
know get a series of albums like imagine
you know one show from every Maiden tour
as a box you know oh wow yeah that would
be cool well one of my biggest ever
regrets or one of my biggest regrets
musically is that sadly I never got to
see uh Black Sabbath play live when deal
was with them um I would dearly because
Mob Rules in particular is is one of my
probably five albums that would be like
desert island disc that I could just put
on repeat and never Tire of listening to
uh and it's a real shame that um I never
got to hear that live but yeah
definitely that sort of thing like dare
I say it compilation album of of best or
compilation set of like best best life
sets by by a band or a range of
different bands that'd be awesome yeah
yeah that would be really cool well we
should we should wrap up we've been
chatting for nearly two hours um and it
I'm it's doubtless getting rather late
by you Ken uh and I'm so happy that you
could join us for this and contribute
your expertise and experience and
memories insights yeah this has been
fantastic for me and I've got to say
that I'm doing a little bit of research
into some you know some stuff I haven't
hi in a little while before beforehand
it's been a real trip down memory lane
so it's been a privilege and thank you
so much for the invite oh ken it's it's
our pleasure we I've been looking
forward to this really Greg can tell you
I've been looking forward to uh having
you on and chatting and hearing your
stories and I so appreciate it I I know
Greg does too and and you've contributed
so much to previous sessions with you
know yes you have comments and insights
and stuff like that so yeah we're
delighted to have had you heavy metal
has been a passion of mine for a long
time all of us yeah yeah I mean that's
that's so that's maybe a good place to
close it's it's really wonderful to get
to get together with people where you
know they they have like a depth
of expertise and you don't have to like
explain everything from the start and
you can say yeah what do you think about
Raven and they're like yeah you know or
pick whatever other band or if you don't
know the band you're like oh who are
they like well they you got to
understand they were like witch find you
know so yeah that's that's
really I mean we'll talk about second
tier bands but yeah second tier
yeah well all right well thanks so much
for for joining us and it's been it's
been great good stuff pleasure all Ken
take care you all right
cheers